halloween approche à grands pas et pour
l'occasion nous sommes actuellement à
l'intérieur d'un des plus grands
magasins a de fait de la région nous
allons voir comment les yvelinois se
séparent pour cette fête à la maison
cette année en compagnie de catherine
bonjour bienvenue chez pas de sensation
merci vous êtes la gérante du magasin
exactement avec mon arrivée rien est ce
que pourrait nous expliquer un peu le
bilan est ce que on décore toujours
notre maison est ce qu'on voulait guise
toujours pour halloween est alors il
reste une fête très populaire et très en
vogue
tout le monde joue le jeu peut-être
toutes générations confondues
petits grands adolescents personnes
âgées
tout le monde aime se jouer deux dames
et vous est ce que vous seriez vous dire
un peu comment les yvelinois se prépare
on s'organise pour cette fête
d'halloween
alors cette année c'est un petit peu
exceptionnel vu la conjoncture actuelle
toutes les familles sont déjà à préparer
à fêter halloween à la maison donc ça se
passe en petit comité de la décoration
bien évidemment des jeu du déguisement
et puis surtout de la créativité dans
les maquillages et si vous avez des
exclusivités notamment un bar à ballon
et un bar à masquer exactement est-ce
qu'on peut aller voir ça bien sûr lb on
y va
[Musique]
on se trouve devant le bar à masquer une
exclusivité à ici dans le magasin est-ce
que quatre pour nous expliquer un peu le
concept alors le concept du bar and ask
c'est bien sûr l'exposition de ce grand
mur avec une multitude de masques de
tout choix que ce soit les animaux et
puis bien sûr les incontournables les
clowns tout ce qui est dément personnage
horrible katrina par les masques quels
sont les accessoires tendances pour
halloween
alors notre clientèle chez fait
sensation aime beaucoup tout ce qui est
transfert fausse cicatrice est également
les lentilles reste les accessoires
incontournables dans une tenue digne
d'halloween et en parlant d'
incontournable ce que je vous propose
c'est qu'on aille voir un peu les
déguisements incontournable avec plaisir
ce que je suis nous voici dans le rayon
des déguisements donc ici à partir de
cet endroit là jusque ici nous avons
tous les déguisements dédié à la fête
d'halloween d'accord rangés par thème
par rayon enfant adulte alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut trouver qui revient un peu
chaque année alors ce qui revient chaque
année bien évidemment dont les enfants
ce sera les sorcières les ventes ur des
petites choses toute mignonne comme la
citrouille et en grandissant on prend
plaisir à carter donc on va aimer les
méchantes fait les sorcières mais aussi
les comptes est diabolique
les vampires et puis vampiresse et pour
les adultes catherine qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve alors j'ai fait sensation vient
surtout chercher des déguisements
d'horreur le client adore tout ce qui
est vêtements ensanglantés
mais également comme pour les enfants
les sorcières les clowns on retrouve
également tout ce qui est jean guy et
puis les kling un évidement terrifiant
horrible toujours pour faire peur
exactement est-ce que vous avez une
tenue un conseiller écouté volontiers je
sélectionnerais bien le costume d'arles
est clean
un personnage partent pour cette année
si vous avez les saignées je vais
l'essayer merci beaucoup 4 à leur merci
d'être venu chez béton façon merci et
moi je vais l'essayer mon costume
[Musique]
bon bah voilà moi je suis prêt de
j'espère que vous l'êtes aussi y'a plus
qu'à décorer la maison et puis à vous
déguiser le jour j
[Applaudissements]